[Music]
this
is star talk sports edition i'm neil
degrasse tyson your personal
astrophysicist and today it's a
materials world
see what we did there we're going to
talk about material science what role is
played
in the progress of sports what role it
will play in the future
sports and let me first introduce my
co-host
gary o'reilly gary hey hey neil gary's
got i love
gotta love gary but we we love your
british accent gary
okay we do because we're all jealous
because in america we have
british accent envy here just so you
know okay uh we don't feel that envy at
home
[Laughter]
a former pro footballer in the uk
back where over where football means
soccer
and so uh great to have you here in star
talk sports edition my other co-host
chuck nice jack hello governor
[Laughter]
okay i don't think that's the accent
we're all jealous of okay
that's i don't girl now
no no we're we're trying to keep it you
know bbc
english not even dick van dyke wouldn't
go there yeah
dick van dyke as in burt in
the verse mary poppins yes
yes just a fri younger than 70 who
wouldn't know that reference
okay oh dear i'm
well none of us have any expertise in
material science so
doing the star talk thing we do we find
someone who does
and uh join me in welcoming
judd reedy from georgia tech judd
welcome to star talk
thank you neil glad to be here
appreciate it excellent excellent you're
an engineer
you got three engineer degrees right
from scratch bachelor's master's
ph.d let me just ask you what percent of
engineering folk actually get phds
because you're so
employable at the master's level it's
judd he's the only one
it's just him there's a couple more out
there for sure but
yeah right now the bachelors my students
here at georgia tech are getting
incredible offers and um and they go on
to to great successful careers in
industry a lot of them come back to
graduate school
either get a technical master's or mba
my wife is an engineer she's getting her
mba right now um
in fact and so okay so so when you need
money you take out loans from them
because you're still in academia yeah
i'm not making money off of anything
that i do here for sure
i'm a state employee working for the
government so
i get good vacation benefits and that's
about it and really good internet
connection
there you go there you go but just to be
clear though most people who will
consume
this this podcast will be hearing the
audio
rather than video let me just say on the
wall behind you you have an entire wall
of plaques
and and and you told us offline that
those are what
yeah that's the great wall of judd those
are all the patents
that we've received
throughout my career so 20 years now of
work
some are electronic materials for
instance
resistors in cell phones other springs
and mattresses
uh some other are don't tell me you can
pat in the spring
no yeah no no micro alloyed yeah yeah
three of them three of them up here
three of them these fancy springs one is
never enough judd huh
no yeah lots of little springs
so that's like you walk into the patent
office i have this new invention
and we ring it and they throw alloys
and they say hey dude that's a spring
right here
it's a microalgae back when you got
something got little dust of titanium
and copper and all sorts of other stuff
inside there with the iron and carbon to
make it
oh so it's what the spring is made of
it's the composite
that you actually pack yeah the alloy in
fact
oh so let me get all your titles
straight here a deputy director
innovation initiatives yeah georgia tech
institute for materials
that's right adjunct professor school of
materials sciences and engineering at
georgia tech
principal research engineer on the
research
faculty the georgia tech research so so
you you're in
you're all in he is all in on this been
here at tech
been here at tech for 18 years now
building up those different titles
and the problem is all three of those
jobs all my bosses think
that that's the only job so i actually
have three three bosses and three jobs
so it
it can be a lot of fun uh sometimes for
sure yeah we'll teach you about
einsteinian time dilation so you can fit
all the jobs into the need
i will teach you about cloning
so so so i let me just sing your praises
explicitly and
implicitly as a material science
engineer uh
you know practically anything that
happens in my field astrophysics
there's a headline there's a black hole
discovered a planet
is demoted we you know the universe is
older or younger
yet you guys are coming up with stuff
all the time
completely transforming how we live
and hardly any of it is heralded
and i just want to just say that i've
been
watching you guys for decades and
watching
all of society shift to accommodate the
materials that you're handing us
and infusing into our products and into
our lifestyle and i just want to
publicly say
thank you for being this this hidden
heroes
of the progress of civilization well
you're very welcome
have you felt the steely gaze of neil
degrasse tyson over your shoulder
there's just so much pressure now for us
to come up with the next
next item but we've been doing this for
thousands of years
if you go back stone age iron age bronze
age
all these are named after a critical
material
information age could be considered
silicon nuclear age these other sorts of
things so
as we go through time uh the materials
are
are extremely important to our evolution
as as civilization
you know i hadn't thought about it that
the stone age the bronze age
that's you guys i had so so in the stone
age
you guys were finding the right stones
to use
that would chip off and make make flats
or that would smash a
bone better than a piece of wood smashed
or would make the cylindrical wheels of
the flintstones car
see you guys would have been but doctor
what is new made
of didn't do yeah as in new age
new age uh certainly the composite
materials are out there
a lot of advanced polymeric chemistry
and i'm not a polymer scientist as well
so i like to collaborate with
some of my friends there um so
you're trying to find things that are
light and strong basically right
that's the thing particularly in sports
is the strength to weight ratio
uh because we can make all sorts of
things out of steel but
god football player wearing steel armor
playing football that's just not going
to make for a very good fighter
that's called the knight the knights the
knights in armor they can't get up once
they
fall so so uh you your specific
specialty
from my notes tells me that you think of
carbon nanotubes
we do i just remind people what those
are or tell them for the first time
a carbon nanotube is um if you're from
the south like i am
is chicken wire um a hexagonal lattice
of carbon carbon atoms that
are then rolled into a cylindrical tube
uh it's
roughly uh 10 or so atoms across if it's
a single wall
nanotube across the diameter a lot of
the carbon nanotubes we grow here in our
lab are multi-wall so it's like a
uh an onion or a russian kachina doll
where they're
nested amongst each other so this is
only
there's no other atoms involved this
carbon
making this six-sided hexagon that
is tiling a the wall of a cylinder
is that what you're describing to us
yeah that's the goal is to have nothing
but carbon-carbon bonds forming these
hexagons uh there's
often always uh some defects so instead
of perfect hexagons
you might get a few pentagons in there
with some dangling bonds that then
attach to oxygens and hydrogens
in the atmosphere would that create a
weakness in your
structure structurally i primarily
use the carbon nanotubes for their
electrical applications we focus on
energy capture storage and delivery for
aerospace applications with an emphasis
on the space so energy capture
like solar cells which we just had a
mission come back from the international
space station
just splashed down last week um going
back again in august
does something just happened in that
sentence that i just want to put it out
there okay
our space shuttle which we no longer
have no longer fly
landed on a runway so when our
astronauts came back from the space
station
they would land but now our access
to space is either by russian
capsule or spacex capsule both of them
um both both of them uh russians land
well they don't splash down but they
like slam down yeah that's right
on the ground so rough them russians boy
let me tell you at the top
they don't land on water they land on
solid ground
uh in a capsule and spacex has returned
the tradition of landing back in
in the water splashdown so i just hadn't
heard splashdown since like the 1960s
so yeah it's great to hear that yeah and
so um so the energy
capture our solar cells we use the
carbon nanotubes to form a
light trapping forest if you will that
we then coat the carbon nanotubes with a
photo absorber
so the photon alike can pinball around
inside that forest
and eventually get absorbed so it
essentially increases the dwell time
of the photon and the photoactive layer
to increase the charge conversion so so
these these tubes are hollow
the tubes are hollow we're using them
just as a as a wire
really as a scaffold to put the material
on that absorbs the light
and then as a electrically conducting uh
member to extract
um the carriers out of that um so are
nanotubes in my life right now
in any way that i can think about um
yeah we've used uh you probably don't
recognize it but
they're very good electrical thermal and
mechanical properties so
they've been incorporated into trays in
silicon fabrication
facilities to carry samples around the
to to reduce the the static build up
there
um so basically it's trivets
they were they put them in um tennis
rackets babalot had a tennis racket
in the early 2000s that included carbon
nanotubes
um also um just to be clear
we're not talking about carbon fiber
here which we've all seen
there's carbon fiber bicycles and carbon
fiber cars
fuselage you know plane and car bodies
so that's not what we're talking about
right nope nope these are
individual carbon nanotubes that have
then been composed
or combined with a matrix material to
strengthen a composite structure
uh i wonder about the actual performance
there i think there's a lot of
advertising benefits
certainly for including the carbon
nanotubes in your tennis racket
uh or or baseball bat but um
the applications we're looking at are
very specialized to
take advantage of of the low work
function of a carbon nanotube for
instance to emit electrons
to serve as a coal cathode for satellite
propulsion and a hall effect thruster
for instance
i didn't i would not have ever imagined
how many different ways you could use
nanotubes
and it's probably only just now plumbing
the surface of what
where could go so so how now sports is
always trying to you know faster higher
stronger have they reached out to carbon
nano people
nano two people for anything yeah um
certainly i've looked at it again like i
was saying with the tennis racket and
the base
baseball bats as well
there's questionable benefits from a
mechanical perspective i think there's
really strong benefits
from a thermal and electrical benefits
to
incorporate it as opposed to say carbon
fiber which is
very very common or or a graphite
which which is just very pure carbon
fiber typically
graphite just that's what's in my pencil
yeah but
you can make it into a fiber structure
so
you take the carbon carbon fiber and you
purify it
even more so that it's instead of 95
percent carbon
it's more like 98 to 99 well that would
make an awesome pencil
and jacket i can draw something with my
jacket sleeve
so so what um what what branches of
sports are most
touched by this do you think or will be
in the future
let me guess race car driving oh
always yeah they've got deep pockets
uh for sure on the automotive worlds uh
the more professional sports they can
can stand to invest in things
and and to have localized applications
of carbon nanotubes say in a helmet or
padding
and those sorts of things i really have
not looked at
getting my own materials into sports
equipment we've tried to use some of the
established
ones out there that are like
commercially viable
so that we can quickly get these
innovations
into the hands of of the of the public
it's really interesting how
um advanced materials like a carbon
nanotube or titanium or carbon fiber
starts out in the military typically uh
and this goes back to bronze age and
stone age as well
um and then it advances into
a commercial application that's very
commonly sports
titanium carbon fiber that's often found
in bicycles and
other sorts of equipment like golf judd
just to take a step back
the applications you've just expressed
what i mean i hear terms like matrix
which gets my ears pricked up then i get
into see
triple bonds and then i hear abs which
sounds like something that comes on my
car
but um can you break that down because
i'm sat there bewildered by a new
language
sure sure so um when you create a
composite structure
you combine two different materials that
have desirable traits
um that when you combine them together
you take those
desirable traits to it to another level
it's it's not simply additive it can
often be
multiplicative and so you will have a
fiber reinforcement
uh like a fabric as well as a polymer
uh like an epoxy and so that epoxy can
form
what we call the matrix and what that
does that
shares the load between your say your
your plies of fiber
or your individual threads and whatnot
and the the different polymers
will have principally a polymeric
component
uh has a carbon-carbon chain
sequenced along and some of those
carbons can be bonded with a single bond
together um for instance like a
polyethylene
or if you have a a double bond between
the two carbons for instance
a like a isoprene polyisoprene that can
make up
uh can stiffen the polymer and so it can
have uh
properties like like a golf ball that
will be much more
rigid than say a latex that has a more
rubbery
just like you're in a kitchen and you
say oh i need this strength and this
flexibility and this weight
and you're just pulling out chemical
bonds
of your ingredients mixing it together
to make exactly what you want and expect
to have and that's what the abs is abs
is a very common polymer
in helmets in
ski boots and a variety of other things
and the a
and the b and the s all stand for an
individual polymer that have been
grafted together to form what's called a
copolymer
so a is acrylic nitrile which has a c
triple bonded with
n which is a very stiff bond and so the
acrylic nitrile provides
a lot of a lot of stiffness what are you
saying and you mean a nitrogen atom
yep sorry okay so cn when i think of cn
i think of
chuck nice cyanide
you set him up he'll knock him down damn
chuck that was quick
uh when i think i've seen i think of um
uh what's the noise in this gas yes
cyanide i think yeah
it's just yes yeah
but but it's it's bound up in the
structure so it's not
um released it's safe okay right
as long as you don't eat your you know
ski boots
how about this judd um so you know is
is there any advancements being looked
at
for these polymers or
uh like even these cardinal the
nanotubes
to change with physical
um surroundings like uh or
so like they become stronger when they
get colder or they become more fluid
when they get hot
oh i love those when they do that i love
those sure
um kevlar is actually one of those that
does get stronger when it's when it's
colder that are people
are familiar with there's other ways
that you can have what are known as
sheer thickening or shear thinning
behavior so that when a stress hits it
it either stiffens up
which can be useful for say for a shock
absorber or something like that or it
can
it can thin out uh and provide a
cushioning uh impact for instance
uh say in panels by a race car um
around a racetrack or something along
those lines they're perfect for ice
hockey
as well wait why what do you need from
um ice cold padding kevlar
if it gets thicker as it's colder so you
stick it out on the ice
then it's going to be good surely so
when i think of kev
when i think of kevin i think of
something that stops bullets so is this
kind of hockey when people shoot you
never seen a truck he just made hockey
the most interesting sport to me ever
now
because instead of just sticks you play
with guns too
that's awesome well i
exactly i mean you get hit by a puck
that's traveling at over 100 miles an
hour that would be classified as a
lethal weapon
my wife when she uh took her very first
trip away
left me at home with our very first baby
well she's also an engineer
she is an engineer civil engineer right
here at georgia tech she got hit by a
hockey puck
at the hockey game and so they she took
that as a bat
as like a sign from the gods um that
maybe she shouldn't leave the baby with
dad for uh i was like
i didn't hit you with a hockey puck baby
yeah i was gonna say she should have
took it as a sign to
give up watching hockey but we we we
she after it bounced off her arm some
dude took it from her she's like hey
that's my puck that hit me
um and so she she got it from him
because she's a strong-willed woman
um and yeah very much
that that you get hit with yeah it's
it's our daughter's teething ring our
daughter's now
but back back then uh we it was their
teeth and ring
we watched that we used we cleaned it
well that's that's okay then
oh that's well i'm sorry that's a scary
no that's like superhero baby if you
hockey puck is your teething ring
i'm sure we've still got it i'm sure
it's amazing it's just like
you cut your teeth on the thing that
almost killed your mother
all right we spent all this time talking
about the the materials
and let's in our next segment uh bring
up
all the ways that they will specifically
be implemented
in the present and future sports when we
come back on star talk sports edition
we're back star talk sports edition gary
o'reilly
hey chuck nice that's right
my intrepid co-hosts and today we're
talking about material science
because it's a materials world and we've
got a material
scientist in our midst uh professor
judd reedy judd from uh georgia tech
welcome
back to star talk good to be back yeah
yeah
it's a great discussions yeah more
discussions and uh
if you've been to georgia tech for a
while at least or
georgian at least since the 1996
olympics
yeah and so they've got a
track down there what are they uh what
they call a mondo
track vulcanized rubber tell us about
what that did to the performance of
[Music]
track athletes yeah the mondo track is
really a key innovation
i was actually a graduate student at
georgia tech when the olympics came so
that was
a fun time to be here and as part of my
class that i teach now here at georgia
tech the materials science and
engineering of sports
we take field trips to all of our
different facilities in the locker rooms
and equipment rooms
and one of the popular ones is our track
so
georgia tech was the olympic village and
so all the athletes were here and they
needed tracks to to train on and so we
got a
awesome track out of the deal uh the
difference between
say an asphalt or a concrete track that
many
um existing tracks are is that is used
using local materials you got the the
concrete aggregate and everything came
from somewhere in that general vicinity
and it's laid down sequentially
in a series of rows from lane one two
three four so on and so forth and so the
uniformity
uh around those different lanes differs
so the durometer the amount of spring
that's in the track
changes whether in your lane one or lane
two or you're at the start or the end of
lane durometer that's in
that's a word that is a word that is a
word and what does that mean
it's the uh return of energy uh
is is a good way of thinking about it
the springiness of okay of the
of the track so the durometrics of the
track i love that
i love it yeah okay so when you run
um there's energy that's lost
on the recoil or energy that's returned
to your bounce
yeah i guess and so uh if you can get
100 of your energy to come back that
would be pretty good
maybe too much perhaps yep you'll see
this a lot of times people
running will run even though there's
perfectly good sidewall it will run in
the street
with the cars for because it's softer on
the joints
for instance yeah um so
the difference with mondo than than the
asphalt which which are laid
sequentially over a period of
several days so the humidity changes i'm
sorry i have to interrupt
um we're just you just distinguished the
softness of asphalt
in a street from the hardness of
concrete on a sidewalk
did you just do that i did yeah okay so
to most people they're both hard so tell
me
where you're coming saying that asphalt
is soft and squishy
relative to the cement laid uh
concrete of us of a of a sidewalk yes uh
just different chemical bonds uh the the
asphalt is typically a petrochemical uh
based
solution so there's a lot of high carbon
acid oil
oil whereas whereas the concrete
food oil okay yeah concrete's typically
more silicate based
and so it's a much stiffer bond and so
as you step on it no matter what type of
material you apply a load to
the bonds between the atoms uh compress
or stretch if you're pulling on it and
uh just the degree to which those
stretches can be um macroscopically
manifest themselves to a feel that you
can feel when you're running on it okay
so this would be the difference between
if i took a hammer
and hit an asphalt street it's a very
different sensation if you take a hammer
and hit a sidewalk
and sound and a different sound right
exactly
and also the asphalt asphalt typically
has very large uh
aggregate like you you can look at the
asphalt and typically see the
the grain structure if you will whereas
concrete will be much much
uh smaller and the smaller the grains
you get typically the stiffer
and stronger materials okay so your
mondo track is even better than asphalt
here's what you're going to say
it is it's the same direction in that
same direction okay so keep going i
interrupted you so much no no
um the the mondo track is
has excellent quality control so it's
made in a factory much like carpet
um as opposed to created on site
and so the very you know the width of
your
it's usually two i believe two lanes
wide
it's uniform all the way along the
length of that
piece of carpet if you will um that's
laid out as well as the width so
no matter what part of the track you're
on always have the same
durometer the same mechanical
performance um
and the same uh response to the
environment for instance uh
shedding of water and those sorts of
things and
okay so it's it's the proverbial level
yeah there you go okay it does and so so
the mondo
also has a really good lifetime
despite being a polymer polymers
typically are not
the best choice outside because the
ultraviolet radiation will attack that
carbon-carbon bond
as well as some of the other carbon
bonds and uh the mondo has
i just have to jump in there because in
my field we think only ever about what
light does to things
so um if i correct me if i'm wrong um
chad the so there's the strength of
any chemical bond between two atoms
you can measure how strong that is so
now you have light coming in
in this case ultraviolet whose energy is
greater
than the strength of that bond it'll
just break the bond that's what's going
on there
so if you had different kind of light
like visible light
or infrared the those photons don't have
enough energy to break the bond and so
the bond is safe in the presence of that
light is that fair to say
yes and different polymers respond
differently so sometimes the
ultraviolet will break the bond other
times it will get harder
it'll it'll create additional cross
links exactly right and so that'll so
that's what dennis used to fix um
fillings and things like that they use
ultraviolet light to seal the bond
yep yep and so that can take your what
was once a nice
flexible pliable rubbery like polymer
and make it very very stiff
okay so this is just the genius of folks
in your profession making
stuff happen that you want to happen
yeah and trying to avoid the ones that
we
don't want to happen command over
chemistry is brilliant okay so keep
going so
all right so all right so now it lasts a
long time and it's uniform
so what why would i run faster on such a
track
oh it's got good energy return um that
that again the springiness but it's
really the competitive
um fairness uh that that plays in the
thickness of the track is maybe
a couple inches thick or so
um but just the uniformity um
makes for a vastly superior product that
it's
not just the track here at georgia tech
is uniform but the same
track that they put say up at emory
university for
practicing on had the same amount
consistency of the properties which has
the same ones
as downtown uh at the olympic stadium so
if i
if i ran a world record at georgia tech
in lane
probably i'd probably run the world
record in lane
six and i probably run the same world
record at
emory but i that may not be the case on
different
on other tracks correct correct and i've
seen several tracks
um my daughter was in the the marching
band that we'd go around and just see
some terrible looking tracks
that you know the the asphalt's just
crumbling up and um
just doesn't provide the the quality of
of feel and now it's an expensive track
so
high schools can't be expected to have a
mondo and that sort of thing
but we've got i got to know if um
if it's all about returning the energy
to the runner
uh is there a limit beyond which
it will not be allowed as a record is
there some rules
about how good you can be at your job
helping athletes there are a lot of
rules that are placed onto
a lot of different materials that are
used in sports from
golf clubs golf balls baseballs all of
these things will have
metrics on them javelins for instance
have
uh javelin got to be really good that uh
people would
basically start throwing them into the
stands uh which is
really rough for uh spectator morale on
that yeah that was that was a guy called
jan zelezny uh a european guy i think
was hungarian he was throwing it
about 90 something meters so if you were
high jumping at the far end from where
he was throwing
you were in danger oh 90 means the full
length of the of the track right
right and then some so so they had to
add like
aerodynamic drag to it yeah they made it
worse
they said why don't you just have them
throw them outside the damn stadium yeah
it's like a restrictor plate
and you know in nascar races and stuff
like that so
wow it's it's anathema to me as a
material scientist breaks my heart
um when they start dumb endowment
materials and
i gotta say though it's a hell of a lot
worse than a hockey puck
because you can't chew you can't chew a
javelin as a child
no it's a heck of a toothpick well i i i
keep want to move on but i have to let
me just give one thing out there
so in principle you could design a track
that returned 100
of your sort of gravitational energy as
you
run from step to step uh if you did
if you can why don't you well uh
certainly cost would be an issue but
that's what you're describing is the
trampoline effect
it's used used in um tennis rackets
baseball softball bats golf clubs
uh and so you just have a thin material
that is able to reflect or respond to
the energy that you impart
upon it now so why aren't tracks
trampolines
um well you begin to get into a you need
some uh resistance uh to push against
like if you've ever tried to run across
an
actual trampoline yeah it's hard yeah
yeah
not so much fun sometimes um so so it's
it's engineering trade-offs
you have to balance it out uh to a
certain once you get a good bouncy thing
going forward you know it could
that's a different kind of race it looks
like a race on the moon yeah
and that's that's just it you going up
and not forward
oh yeah that's right because you need
the friction to go forward whereas
the trampoline is really good at making
you go up yeah for instance you could
have have that better
um more springy substance near the high
jump pit for instance where you def
where you're not as worried about your
forward motion as your upward
motion or the you can have like
your starting blocks could be a
precocked
trampoline facing forward oh that would
be good
so your first step so you don't have
this time where you have to get up your
speed
you you hit your top speed instantly
that'd be cool
fires you should we should we should
make that happen and chuck you want what
kind of big cat behind the blocks
no i i mean we talked about that i would
just like to i would just like to see
people
shot out of the blocks if i could that
people no no
and then you open a tiger cage and then
they're running after you will break
records all the time but let's get back
to the other things for example
uh recently uh when exactly was it uh
gary when
the two-hour marathon record oh this
goes back to the doctor's point about
banning materials and not seeing the the
sort of constrictions
nike have a shoe out called the vapor
fly and i think they've even called it
the alpha fly and the dream has always
been
break two hours for the marathon right
um and 2019 uh koji
the kenyan runner who's 34 years of age
broke the two-hour barrier by about 40
20 or 40 seconds
and he did it wearing nike shoes and
there's
uproar but the thing is the the
thickness of the sole but they've got a
little special ingredient doctor don't
they what
what have they put in those nike shoes
that makes them so special
yeah that's a they've got chemical dna
for sure they've got carbon fiber plates
in the base that provide an energy
return and i'm not
a runner i only run if i'm being chased
so that doesn't happen
too much anymore but the the return of
energy um through these series of plates
are as much like a spring um and
just the concept of a uh a two hour
marathon i mean that's 13 miles an hour
that you're averaging
running through there which is a very
fast just regular run yeah
so this record uh was broken but no i
wouldn't say smashed so
one hour 59 minutes 40 seconds
but the thing is neil but so why so so
wait so why are people complaining just
everybody wear the nike shoes so what
because at first they called it kleenex
they did the pop-up
tissue first so band-aid if you do it
first and best right
these are the rules these are the rules
you see
the the the technology has to be
available to
basically everybody if you want to
compete in these shoes they have to have
been available to the public
for something like four months prior
that's correct
which i don't know you know it's it's a
competitive advantage i mean that's the
whole
thing that about competing because
you're trying to be better than somebody
wait
no stop stop stop stop okay stop neil's
not happy
don't have rockets in them
no it is your energy
it is the management of your running
energy
in the soles of your feet so it is still
me running that distance in that time
now it'd be something different if i had
rockets and stuff and just don't need
neil you don't need rockets when you're
elite and i'm guessing
because i've never been there at that
level because don't forget
koji breaks the two hours he already
holds the official
world record for the marathon right
nike claim something like three to four
percent
improvement in your race times now for
an elite athlete
that's a gold medal it helps
it helps us non-elite athletes too yeah
i just
i just i haven't for me that would just
be finisher
people doing that because let's just run
barefoot you know if you've got issues
with shoes
i was about to say the guys from kenya i
mean
somebody is going to break the world two
hours without shoes
shoes no no they do they're not even
gonna be wearing shoes because that's
how
that's their culture but no they do i
mean back in 68
yeah oh yeah gabriel ran barefoot yeah
yeah in fact he started out with shoes
if i remember correctly and he just
didn't like him
yeah because they were brand new shoes
he just took him off and finished the
race
you know so we got to keep moving
through these topics so for tell me
about
you know where are what's the status of
golf balls now
golf balls is one of the most fun labs
that i have during my class i've got
some examples here so
they started out way back in the
1400s as knots of wood and
rocks which golf is kind of a miserable
sport anyway it's amazing that it took
off when you were hitting
rocks of wood you know imagine putting
that thing
and so then they got slightly better
where they boiled goose feathers and
stuck them inside the bladder and made
these things called featheries
those had much uh truer flight
but you introduced the situation where
you would literally explode the ball
if you hit it too hard plus if you hit
them in the water
despite being goose feathers that were
boiled that made your balls soggy so you
couldn't use it anymore
they then moved on to what's known as
gutta percha
uh and those are the so-called gutties
uh golf balls
which was a polymer it's a naturally
occurring
sap from the from the tree uh the
gutta-percha tree
and that produced a very uniform
ball uh that could be made in in large
quantities
then they started to incorporate
additional things for instance
this one's all rolled up now but it has
basically a rubber band
that's wrapped around a solid core
inside it
and that provides uh
golf is a game of feel as they they
describe it so that there's
benefits to rolling and backspin and
other types of aspects of flight
now they've got a variety of polymers
but just a sec so baseballs are
for a while if not still we're also a
rubber band wrapped around a
core got one right here oh okay so
you're holding
he's holding up uh did your dog chew on
that baby
this is a georgia tech uh baseball that
uh for my class we took it apart because
we're highlighting
the differences in materials as sports
materials have gone along they almost
always or they do always start out as
natural materials wools and wooden
materials and leathers and baseball gets
the award for natural materials using
wood bats leather gloves
pine tar spit cotton fabric in here
they're untouched by your magic yeah in
so many ways which is really
disappointing because we can make it
some baseball let me tell you i was
going to say no wonder baseball's so
boring
so what is the the latest uh golf ball
costing us the latest greatest golf ball
oh man
um it's a it's this five piece ball here
so it's got
five layers of different material in
there
providing a very hard center for your
carry
a the outer shell will have some uv
stabilizers so again so that the
ultraviolet doesn't harm it but also
so it has the lower friction as it flies
through the air
air um just so you know this this cross
section of the golf ball
the latest golf little bit that you're
now showing me is
uh it looks like a cross-section of a of
a planet
it is and they they talk about the
mantle and the crust
oh they do yeah there you go yeah that's
exactly how we describe it and
and just like the earth each one of
those layers has a different
uh consistency and mechanical properties
to it to provide
either the the dense mass to
to have some carry or a little bit of
resiliency to it so that you can
induce uh spin onto so once again you're
combining multiple properties to get
one generalized effect that people seek
correct
so is that the future of golf that that
golf ball
the golf industry is regulated they
don't want the golf balls to fly
too far because golf courses are very
expensive to build so
certainly once again now a par three and
you gotta buy the neighboring lots and
other sorts of things so
no it's serious i've got issues
imagine you've you've bought your
beautiful golf course
in a beautiful part of the world and
someone comes along and they now start
to hit it 500 yards
and your golf course is built for maybe
a 375
400 that's because [ __ ] like jed
reedy are making my game better
so you can't go buying up land around
your golf course because it's just too
expensive so all of a sudden
yeah especially because you can hit it
500 yards into the woods and so now it
goes like over the
guy's house into the next yard beyond
that okay so how about the poles they
use in pole vaulting
my my father ran track i think they were
bamboo or something right i mean yeah
we've come a long way i was actually a
pole vault your father didn't use bamboo
did he no when he ran track
his fellow track athletes were using
bamboo who were hydro
yeah the original polls were bamboozled
yeah bamboo
bamboo was up until uh just a little bit
after world war ii
uh yeah yeah that's when he was there
yeah and in fact the baton was made of
bamboo
uh in the relay races so well you know
that i can see
i mean i'm not trying to you know i'm
just i'm
how natural materials were still
infusing right
and what we were doing so what what are
what are they made of now
yeah now they're they're composites um
so they went it's it's really a great
story if you look at the
world records you can see clearly the
aluminum the bamboo era then it stops
and then aluminum and then it plateaus
out and then now we're in the composite
area
because you can take those composites
and just like we were talking about the
energy return you can
preferentially put reinforcements
where that pole is bending as opposed to
an aluminum which would be
uniform throughout the properties
throughout the length of it and so you
can
preferentially put springiness where you
want it to
have greater and greater um heights
could you ever make one so springy that
like the javelin you could just
pull vault out of the stadium
pole vault has some great rules the pole
vault basically has no rules
whatsoever the only rule is that you
have to carry the pole
um like you have to carry it in yourself
um so
you can make it out of any sort of
material you want now there are
some uh good wisdom
and and you want to have this certain
diameter pull for your weight
and uh your style of jumping where where
you want the pole to bend
so that it doesn't fracture which are
some of the most incredible
uh videos that i like videos
before we jump out to a break we got to
jump out to a break do you
can you build a kick point like a hockey
stick into a pole vault and get that
extra sure they already do that yeah
that's that's standard they
very much reinforce specific areas of
the pole
um to to do it so the pole is not a
uniform
material from bottom to top which is why
if you carry it the wrong way
you get a whole different outcome
definitely make sure to put the right
end into the pit
reverse it and put the wrong end that
leads to just so you know
a former a guest a brief guest on star
talk
buzz aldrin uh the uh of the apollo 11
crew to the moon
uh he was a track and field athlete and
did the pole vote
when he was in college so i just thought
i'd say that before we go to break
when we come back more of star fox
sports edition
it's a materials world
we're back star talk sports edition with
judd
reedy our special guest today a material
science
engineer and of course i got gary and
chuck my co-host
jack all right hey so uh so this is what
we call the shoot the ship
segment where we just sort of unpack so
much of what we've just discussed
so first of all our crack team of
researchers reminded us of who finished
the marathon
in bare feet it was 1960 and ethiopian
abbey tequila
so it was not 68 on that yeah sorry
apologies
yeah yeah so but you know it was close
he's black and from africa so yeah
exactly
it won't make a difference what year it
is oh come on guys this is what year it
is you know it's going to be some black
dude from africa
i apologize i didn't get the right
athlete that's my bad haven't you seen
chariots of fire i mean come on
no yeah those movies were wearing shoes
and it was in the movies
that happens in the winter tracks not
not any mondo or even
asphalt my father ran cinder track yeah
and he would tell us about
if you fall the center would go under
your skin
and you'd get horrible it was very very
bad um a point we didn't get to in the
second segment let's see if we can
dispatch with this quickly
tell us about sharkskin swimming suits
what's going on there yeah
yeah so sharkskin that made a big deal
in the olympics uh it was a
a suit that uh it was polyurethane was
the
was principally the the polymer that was
involved and
that has the benefit of floating uh
in water and so it provided uh
assistance to the swimmer to keep them
from drowning basically so that your
energy could be focused on going forward
i never knew that because swimmers have
very low body fat and
body fat floats and muscle sinks
yeah i mean it wouldn't hold i mean you
couldn't float like you were in the
distance but a little bit
but it's a little bit matters correct it
does at these these levels a fraction of
it does so that was one benefit that it
was just inherently buoyant
so why don't they just wear one of those
life preservers yes
a little little bit of drag on that one
just go with swimmies
swimming right wow okay so okay i get
that so they're a little more buoyant
so they're but they were also hollow the
the the fibers themselves were hollow so
air could be introduced as well that's
how they that's how they get the
buoyancy
and then and then furthermore the
topography the surface characteristics
of the
of those of the swimsuit
uh had texture on it that would disrupt
the boundary layer
where the water is touching the surface
uh to
uh transition that between laminar and
turbulent flow so that it released
and so that there was so this is like
what like the surface of a golf ball
correct correct it breaks it it
separates the
the flow of the fluid around it whether
it's air for a golf ball or water for a
swimmer
to allow less friction so so was it was
it outlawed when it first happened i'd
catch me up on the news on that it
lasted for an olympics uh
and a ton of records were set all during
that that period of time with astrid
marks and everything next to him now i'm
sure
um and then they just said no we can't
have this
the other thing is they were full body
suits that they provided
compression so it reduced the cross
section of the swimmer like it squeezed
them in
so there was less again less friction
through the water uh but the compression
also increases your your muscular
ability
uh so there was a whole bunch of really
good benefits
sounds like everything's good what's the
problem i know what's the problem like
again they're putting you out of nothing
if i'm a material
you know they want to make it i guess
fair for everybody to have
accessibility to these same things much
like the shoes
have to be available and so everybody
gets a suit
actually it's gonna be like an oprah
show you'll get a suit and you'll get
and you get a suit and you get a suit
okay so you guys must have a museum
of the cost of being too good at your
job of the things that got stopped
because you represented too much of an
advantage over everybody else
just the man i'm really tired that's a
sad museum
all right doctor i mean for i've maybe
it's just me
i've long held this idea of
electronically powered garments
whether they would change color whether
you could change
sort of advertising on uniforms or
whatever it is
apart from a battery pack stuck to the
side which isn't really efficient
where are we now with these sort of
things or am i just going to continue
this dream
now we can begin to capture energy from
all sorts of sources obviously solar
power is available
uh but because you're in a sporting
event there's a lot of mechanical
energy available we already talked about
kind of kind of the passive return of
energy through the shoes but you can
use what's known as a piezoelectric
material that converts
mechanical energy to electrical energy
like a quartz
for instance you can do that you can
also have electrical that converts to
to mechanical so you can capture that
energy uh and then store it in a in a
usable
manner such as in a capacitor or a
battery um
to to deliver that to provide
communication capabilities for instance
a wi-fi
or a bluetooth type communicator to
transmit
athlete health performance you know
simple stuff like
uh respiratory rates and heart rates or
more complex things like
ph of your sweat or the amount of
adrenaline or other
sort of stress inducing or stress
signifying chemicals
that the body secretes now i always
thought that the
at a fitness center where they have sort
of the treadmill and you're watching tv
that you should be powering that
television
oh yeah yeah and so and if you stop
walking the television shuts off so if
your best part
that means you got to keep going and
what really should happen is all fitness
centers of the world
should feed the energy back into the
grid correct
look at how much energy we're burning
and not doing anything with it
that and and capture the kindergartens
too because they're
all the energy there's a lot of a lot of
bouncing around in those kindergartens
for sure
yeah you'll have child labor laws for
that for sure
yeah but no i mean are we going to get
to this point where we get super smart
closing
yeah i think that's that's where we're
at right now is the history of sports
has all been
about strength to weight ratio and so
that's why we've got composites and
we're using
the light metals like aluminum and that
phrase strength two weight ratio
is you want as much strength as you can
with the least weight
correct because putting something into
motion you can make it go faster if it
weighs less
correct and you can accelerate it more
nimbly if it weighs less so
i just want to clarify strength two
weight ratio cap encapsulates all of
that
right yep it normalizes it out and it
makes it
um you know that's the reason why we
have titanium titanium is not
inherently better than steel from a
strength perspective but it's way way
less less so it's it performs better
when you normalize that all right so let
me ask you this talking about strength
to work well
one other thing wait before we go chuck
i need you to verify what i've been
telling people but you're a materials
guy
and i just want to put it out there okay
everyone thinks
titanium is some magic new substance but
it is one of the most common ingredients
in earth's crust
and it's just that it took us a long
time to figure out how to
extract it um in
an affordable way to be used
it took us a while to figure out how to
make it economical so is that a fair
statement that's a very fair statement
just because it's prevalent in the
earth's crust much like rare earth
materials sound like they should be not
abundant
they're they're everywhere but they're
not in mindable quantities i mean
it needs to be concentrated in a place
where you can dig out
just many many millions of tons of this
material
right by the way uh thank you china
because they pretty much own the rare
earth
that's true business now so that's
pretty much true yeah
once again america fallen behind um all
right
yeah but get back to what gary said you
know everything was strength to wait but
where we're going in the future is
multifunctionality that
it's more than just mechanical benefits
we're wanting to look at the thermal
benefits particularly as it applies to
uniforms and clothing or
say tires on a on a
race car or a bicycle you want to
capture
the electrical opportunities to have
sensors built into your clothing
i mean we've got it now with a fitbit
but could we have it inherently within
the structure
to again to capture body temperature or
respiratory rate or things
things like this and then one of the
biggest ones and people giggle about it
odor control i've got a design component
of my uh class here at georgia tech and
the athletes it's called the bo class it
is it is
over and over again i just ran i just
ran a marathon and i smell like
lavender
you rode the taxi cab chuck that's the
thing hanging from the mirror
yeah yeah yeah so um let me ask you this
strength to wait both you and neil
um so in baseball you hear some
players talk about they want to use a
heavier bat
is that preference or is there a
mechanical advantage for a player of a
certain size
to swing a heavier bat thereby
letting me ask you can something be too
light
even though it is strong enough to do
the job
yeah let me reshape that question for
jen if
uh so i have a certain uh have a certain
strength right
and so should i swing the heaviest
bat possible where i can still come
around to make contact with the ball
that's the key or or should i spring a
lighter bat
that i could might be able to swing
twice as fast for example
yeah the most players prefer a much much
uh heavier bat
but you can't get it around in time so
it's it's very much a personal
preference to
to get it down to a controllable
uh weight but you want it as heavy so
the two competing factors there is the
point
yeah there's a there's clearly a
crossover point baseball players are so
freaking superstitious anyway that you
can't change their bat
at all anyway but to be able to
scientifically assess how you hit that
bat
that's some of the stuff that people are
doing now
to to match the club
with with the player like they do in
golf all right so how about
how about the fact that in any uh
expenditure of energy
of the human body the body temperature
warms and as such the body temperature
now
wants to cool itself can you have
clothing
that whisks away the extra heat and then
converts that is is heat energy so
low quality that you can't do anything
with it at that point
and you just got to dissipate it it is a
challenge uh certainly having delta t
the difference in temperature have a hot
and a cold you can do something with
that
the the inherent uh prevalence of the
heat itself
generally you just want to get away from
the athlete and that's some of the
technology
we've been developing georgia tech with
some research partners
that promote wicking through the fabric
we've got a
a student of mine that he was a wide
receiver
and realized that uh fumbling of
football is a bad thing
um as a wife and so he created these
these called lizard sleeves that has a
sticky side if you will on one side and
a slippery side on the other side so the
slippery part you put on the
exterior uh like the defender side of
your fork tackling
yep and so you shed the defenders with
that
whereas the sticky side is is on your on
the ball carry inside
uh so that you can hold the ball better
now it's not a coating
or anything it's it's a knit it's what's
called a warp knit so there's several
different fibers in there
and the way the knit comes together the
sticky fiber which is a spandex
type fiber is on the outside of the surf
surface so uh that coating can't wear
off
um it's it's just inherently uh built
into the structure
and once again inside being clever is
you were so clever that they now
outlawed it what's the future
not yet and so not yet yeah exactly it
seems like they rule everything out and
so we're going to
make a go of it for the next five years
till they create a rule against it
probably
um but but you know the knit was
important because you can't have the
sticky on the inside because you
wouldn't be able to
get it on your sleeve so it needs to be
slippery
on the skin skin surface now um
wide receiver gloves uh have have a
similar um
tacky like construction you can't allow
them to just stick their hand up
high above the head the ball just sticks
to the hand yeah you can't use stick
them anymore that's that's been
outlawed but the wide receiver gloves
are still okay um those have
um silicone uh pads on on the
on the fingers and the palm this is not
an add-on this is again
inherently in there and uh at the
at the youth levels and the college
levels there are no rules that
would prohibit this from from football
we've
but nfl maybe we've found it's useful
actually in covid because nobody was
playing football when we were developing
this
it's great for package delivery workers
uh people in warehouses
far anytime you got to carry something
even healthcare workers
doing physical therapy if you've got to
move a heavy patient
it helps you grab grab them and right so
then you don't have to squeeze as hard
to
to boost the friction because you're
getting the friction for free from the
material correct
it's got the tackiness built in and
that's that's all in the weave
it's in the weave exactly right yeah so
okay so so
far this this show we've learned that
cooking for materials is good
and now it's knitting yup okay
i mean we've you've gone back to the
future there's some simple
things that we do that achieve amazing
things now
there's only so so many ways you can
fabricate things and it's adding a new
you know recipe from our spice rack the
periodic table is my spice rack so i can
i can pick and choose things
from there uh to yield the ultimate um
performance here's what i want to do i
want to have another show
uh on the other side of the house uh
star talk flagship where we just talk
about the geeky things you can do with
the periodic table of elements
and what you what goes through your head
when you walk up to that spice rack
say today i want to make this and i just
want to have a conversation with you
when you make two parts silicon one part
oxygen three parts carbon
i want to have that conversation will
you come back for us to do that i will
i've got my periodic table right here
never leave home without it
excellent we got to call it quits there
judd it's been great having you on this
we love getting
geeking out with you here and there's no
end of sports maybe we'll get you back
during the olympics
and we'll uh be right in the middle of
what's up and figure out all the ways
that the things you've come up with will
not be
in the olympics the blades the blades on
the
on the skates everybody thinks those are
flat they're not flat they're concave so
you actually got two little blades on
we did a whole show on that yeah so cool
we've done that
we've got a whole show on that one so
all right dudes uh we're calling it
quits there
uh chuck gary always a pleasure pleasure
my friend all right this has been star
talk sports edition neil degrasse tyson
your personal astrophysicist
you